gp uh you've come up with some new ways
of saying and doing
so many things that i wanted to tap you
to come up with some euphemisms or
drupamisms to have some alternative
words because it turns out
in the daytime tv space there are only
certain words you can say and certain
words you cannot say
will you help me yeah so i'll try
okay all right
figuring out new language for daytime tv
with my friend gp
okay gwyneth our control room is on
standby to cut us off if we say anything
that goes too far
all right i need something for butt
because you're only allowed to say it
once and i just said it so
help me go gp
derriere took us
reserved seating
built-in beanbag chair
the old rumplestiltskin
two scoops
the great divide
[Applause]
okay next since we can't swear
i need alternative aka drew feminisms
for curse words gp go
what what do we yell instead of a curse
word uh
crackers
[Music]
[Applause]
jimmy fallon
our control room is going bananas okay
we cannot refer to another part of the
anatomy
and it starts with v and ends with aina
gp go ah
ladybits find chyna
pepperoni roll personal pan pizza
uh life's cornucopia
i mean it is a
little pat of butter
loan mittens
in the honor of the zucker brothers an
old-school nickelodeon you can't do that
on television
that was drew feminism's with none other
than the genius brilliant goddess
gwyneth paltrow
[Music]